that stephen mats is making his 22nd
start coming off a pretty good start
against seattle had four strikeouts
against the mariners and he picked up
his 10th win of the season and that'll
bring up miguel cabrera for the first
time today some of the people by now
should be aware of uh the milestone that
he is trying to hit home run number 500
if he gets it or when he gets it
whenever that is he'll become the 28th
player all time to reach 500 home runs
this is a long run for three different
blue jays and it'll be simeon making the
catch down the line not a routine play
by any stretch of the imagination a good
start to this ball game for steven matz
well pitching for the tigers today will
be drew hutchinson he's got a three
pitch mix 94 mile per hour fastball and
he has a real good feel for his
secondary pitches his change up and his
slider he holds his own here's the 1-1
sharply to short
and an easy play for zach short and
that'll bring up alejandro kirk the 2-2
bounced towards the hole and threw into
left field to base in hit by hit all the
time getting more and more comfortable
there's lourdes gorilla
lined to right field a base hit for
gurrielle
kirk up to second on the play
kevin smith getting another start today
his second of the series
smith sends a drive to left center
hill dives and he makes the grab
oh my goodness
derek hill out of nowhere
this was impressive
the speed the athleticism the style
he's given up two hits and a walk
through two but no runs allowed
as beau buchet bounces one up the middle
for a base hit to begin the third
as he was looking for a first pitch
breaking ball and does a good job to
start the inning with the lead off
single
so now marcus simeon
and a base hit into left field
so the first two men have reached here
in the third inning another slider and
watch the location it breaks but it
still stays on the inner half and marcus
stays on it and hooks it past the third
baseman so now it's two on with nobody
out for guerrero
ground ball to third to second one
and a double play and another
opportunity
for one of their best hitters their best
hitter with the runners in scoring
position to put a ground ball right at
somebody unfortunately for a double play
so let's see if t oscar hernandez can
pick him up get something going here
that one will get through the legs of
candelario and the blue jays catch a big
break
should have been the end of an inning
instead it's a run-in and a
one-to-nothing blue jays lead
but this is unfortunate because it's hit
right to it and you can see he just
didn't stayed out
the ball
stayed under his glove kicked off his
heel went into foul territory
candelario rips one to left
into the corner guriel will have to play
it off the wall candelario hustles for
two and he is in there with his 33rd
double of the season
matt's got a spin in fire and he makes a
good play boy that was tricky but a nice
job by matt's
going on what type of hitter he was and
that's how you call the game
what a stop at third by smith back to
his feet and dugout at the other end by
vlady
what a play by kevin smith kevin smith
playing his first game in the big
leagues at third looks like he's been
there his whole life this is a bullet
one hop he dives fully extends and look
at the arm strength it gets a nice
stretch over it first from vladi
guerrero as well
and that's a terrific play by a young
player third baseman and you can see
he's pretty pleased he saves extra bases
right here for steve and matt's no doubt
about it that was a double all the way
miguel cabrera
seven time silver slugger award winner
the 1-1
deep fly ball right center field that's
got kerry it's gone number 500 and
history for miguel cabrera
and his fans and his teammates
are both loving it
his teammates
pour out of the dugout and this crowd in
toronto on their feet
the welcoming committee from every
teammate as he heads down those dugout
steps
there have been more than 20
000 players in major league history
miguel cabrera has become the 28th
to hit 500 home runs what a moment well
guys we've been anticipating the 500
home run we've been waiting for the 500
home run well here it is it's an 84 mile
per hour change up
off the plate away
and yeah the big fella covers it the
opposite way i love it
take that curtain call
you deserve it
corey dickerson's over three
ground ball to the left side throw is
not in time
boy with the shift on candelario just
kind of never got squared up and the
play slow developing and dickerson beats
it out shortstops make this play all the
time but because candelario's in the
shift at the shortstop position you can
see he doesn't get much on the throw can
lourdes goriel jr
come up with a big hit to give the blue
jays the lead and break this log jam of
not getting a hit with runners in
scoring position
there it is
dickerson around third heading home and
the blue jays have the lead
well that snaps an over 27 for the team
batting with runners in scoring position
as guriel just stays on it another good
hit to right field dickerson running
with two outs got a great jump he's way
to willy castro with two outs in the
night
[Music]
golf's one to left center field
that's hit well and that'll bounce over
the wall a ground rule double for willy
castro tigers
have the tying run at second and the
go-ahead run coming to the plate
you see the sidearm
stays away from him harold castro
hitting for dustin garneau
now the 2-2
ground ball to second simeon takes care
of it oh and then guerrero couldn't come
up with it it was in the dirt and we're
tied
the toronto defense lets them down
tigers are still alive it's 2-2
and this time he bounces it and gave
vladi a tough short hop takes a lot of
time throws it in the dirt and it gets
away from blatty and of course with two
outs the runner running all the way
around scores easily
now the payoff
scope drives one
to center field grichik is under it he's
got it
short will tag and score the tigers have
the lead 3-2 on the sacrifice fly from
jonathan scope in the 10.
he's going
and kirk sends a fly ball to left field
it is deep enough for sure to get
guerrero home as he will tag and come
into score
and the blue jays have tied it
as cameron search of his first hit today
now the 3-1
ripped to left at a base hit
that'll drive home grossman
dash cameron will dig for second he's
got himself an rbi two out double here
in the 11th to push the tigers back in
front
the one two to castro
to left field another base hit
cameron's gonna score
all the way to the wall castro has his
second straight double this one drives
in a run an insurance run and the tigers
lead by two
the o2
that's good stuff
froze him and the tigers win it
in 11
and win the series in toronto